I can't believe I'm saying this but
YouTube has gotten stale lately YouTube
used to be the place to go to find cool
obscure videos by independent news
creators like this or this it was
basically the antithesis of cable TV
where everything is sanitized and you
know exactly what you're going to get
YouTube used to have an effect that I'd
like to call the duty black hole where
you'd get on to see a rhett and Link
video and find yourself three hours
later watching windsurfing fails
compilation number seven or the ultimate
showdown of ultimate destiny all through
jizz clicking on related videos in the
sidebar it's a bit like going down the
rabbit hole
and Alice in Wonderland but YouTube has
made it harder to have this experience
finding fresh content this is a screen
capture of when I recently went to watch
a redneck video on this channel look at
the sidebar options which should be the
primary way to find new related channels
the first page full is all rhett and
Link and a few options that are
different at the very bottom our
channels that I already have subscribed
to there's absolutely nothing new to
find here how did this happen well I did
some digging and it has to do with the
YouTube algorithm that's what determines
what results were favored to show up
when you search something it's exact
inner workings are more preciously
guarded than the krabby patty formula
but people have been able to figure out
pretty much how it works a few years ago
YouTube changes formula to pay for watch
time in other words they'd rather show
you a video that will keep you on their
site for 30 minutes than one that will
keep you on for 10 minutes and that
makes sense business-wise but it's also
why it's so hard to find new channels on
YouTube basically it comes down to this
YouTube wants to suggest videos that it
knows you're already likely to enjoy
that's the only thing it knows that you
already like is what you've already
watched this means it's only going to
feed you more of the creator's you
already know and look I'm fine with
being shown more about subjects that I
watch but it seems like lately that's
all YouTube will recommend we need a new
way to discover videos and if any of you
suggest a training tab I'll put you
through that wall it's just a bunch of
TV late-night host
movie trailers or other mass appeal
videos
I don't need help finding the youtubers
I already watch I know who they are I
want to be able to find new creators
I've never heard of that's what made the
YouTube experience special but YouTube
needs to change its algorithm to take
more risks with suggestions or we're
going to all get tired of watching more
of the same content we always watch in
summary YouTube you're getting boring
these days and it's time to spice things
up yours conditionally the audience hey
looks good thanks for watching that
video and you know I think the best
video not the video you found that you
looking for but the one that you found
that you want look employed exists just
right so if you guys have had an
experience like that recently let me
know if you haven't let me know thanks
for watching you can subscribe here to
watch another video here and I will see
you guys next Wednesday